neither you ever flown a drone before
here you go
my toe in the air - be careful boys oh
yeah what are you doing I just got this
nice little drone with a camera in the
front because as a camera in the front
means he can record stuff while flying a
little drone it's got bigger battery
because it's got a camera in it I don't
know how much that's Joey dit is the
other drones are pretty fun almost
everybody here ended up getting the
original little drones and this is only
like 15 20 dollars more than the other
ones let's give it a shot let's see what
looks like
my drone friend you are worse than a cat
I had to is moving
Oh
yes dear
oh my god you okay yeah today's a day
for another drone flight I need a camera
mounted drone a broken processor look in
the room this one's missing the drone
got a little camera on it
like no one's here
but the route passes okay all right
after standing around for half an hour
trying to get this dang thing working
now we are in business
so Carmichael if you crash it a little
part of me will be happy
okay today I'm gonna make Carmichael
take us out we have a flight around and
tell him to get a couple tool shots now
when it comes to cool shots lateral
motion diagonal motion motion that
expresses what you're trying to get
trying to reveal something falling
backwards great trying to focus the
viewers eye onto something pushing in
works great trying to let us contemplate
our existence a side to side to them it
works pretty well
funny thing is you might think it's
faster to go down than it is to go up
with a drone it is actually not true
because the drone creates a wash with
its rotor blades so as it's going down
like whoo whoo whoo whoo whoo when
trying to balance through that wash not
to mention if you go down too fast and
the drone s really work hard to stop
that downward with my momentum so it
kind of limits you to a nice steady
descent people make mistake of falling
up really high minute left on my battery
so I better bring it back in
then that minute runs out when they are
happy back then it comes down real fast
after that all right so this drone does
not take off as fast as the other one
meaning you are going to you take off
with confidence guests Oh so let's give
Carmichael some space Peter
great nice confident takeout that's what
I like where you're flying a drone to
the camera on it you shouldn't look at
the video feed occasionally check the
video feed to make sure you're getting
what you want to get for the most part
it's going to be check your starting
frame check your ending frame but
everything else you're going to fly by
your line of sight the thing is this
drone uses Wi-Fi there's actually a 1/2
second leg so if you're trying to do any
term innumerous off the video feed it's
just not fast enough
three two one rolling Carmichael give me
a cool epic shot of us here rotating
oh hey
I'm trying to think of what the shot is
while I'm flying
so you'd also change the tilt of the
camera with this little wheel under your
finger so check your start frame y'all
set okay and make a shot in glance as
you go yeah I went the wrong way on the
camera
one more time all right and forward this
is really difficult the camera wheel
functioned as if I was looking at the
monitor so when I'm looking at this I'm
trying to push up and I'm thinking
inverted with a 1 here it's not inverted
uh-huh
uh-huh
showoff
Hollywood
one so my preferred method of landing
this is to actually catch it rather than
to set it onto the ground can be
dangerous for your fingers that's why I
have to just be slow and careful nice
and slow
phantoms are really steady and grab the
feet then you have to hold it steady
because if you start tilting it it's
going to fight against you because it's
going to try to stay level so you just
hold it steady
and it's going to just quiet down like a
like a dog with the bag over its head
and eventually turn off Oh calm down
like a bird with a blanket over its cage
right right